tell us about your new show though  because i love that you're only in shows  with titles i can't  say on my show yeah i mean it doesn't it  doesn't take a genius to realize that  i've kind of  graduated from from  my new show which i'm so proud of  is called kevin himself and  you know how many sitcoms  are about this kind of schlubby beer  drinking sports  lovin dude yes with the hot wine it's  not about him  yeah it's about his wife and  his wife is tired of being the butt of  jokes and the server of sandwiches  and she's really mad and she's really  frustrated  and she decides to kind of take matters  into her own hands  and uh that in a very uh vague nutshell  is what the show's about  okay so this is basically like a lot of  women's daydream  [Laughter]  the more i think about it the more i i  think yes absolutely yeah  yep i'm still here just waiting for you  to subscribe  if you don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever help